SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BIG NEWS IN THE POLITICAL WORLD.
HOURS AGO JOB TOOK GROVE
JOE BIDEN’S HANDLERS ANNOUNCED
THEY SELECTED
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA TO RUN AS JOE BIDEN’S
VICE PRESIDENT.
WE DIDN’T SEE IT COMING.
JUST LAST NIGHT ON THE SHOW WE
TOLD YOU SUSAN RICE WILL LIKELY
TO GET THE JOB.
RICE IS A HARDENED PARTISAN BUT
SHE’S NOT STUPID.
MORE TO THE POINT, RICE’S
SINCERE BELIEFS WHETHER YOU LIKE
THEM OR NOT.
KAMALA HARRIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF
THAT.
HARRIS MAY BE THE SINGLE MOST
TRANSACTIONAL HUMAN BEING IN
AMERICA.
THERE ARE TIME-SHARE SALESMEN
YOU WOULD TRUST MORE THAN
KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU COULD FIND PAYDAY LENDERS
WHO ARE MORE SINCERE.
SO IT SEEMED INCONCEIVABLE THAT
GIVEN HIS CURRENT STATE,
JOE BIDEN TO SOMEONE SO
TRANSPARENTLY ONE-DIMENSIONAL AS
KAMALA HARRIS.
SOMEONE IS HE IS.
IT WOULD BE THE FIRST ENTIRELY
HOLLOW PRESIDENTIAL TICKET IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND WE THOUGHT
IT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
BUT THEY ARE DOING IT ANYWAY.
BIDEN-HARRIS, THAT’S WHAT THEY
ARE GOING WITH.
THE CHOICE TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AMERICA IS STILL TECHNICALLY A
DEMOCRACY YET EITHER BIDEN NOR
HARRIS HAS EVER BEEN POPULAR
WITH ACTUAL VOTERS.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN’S THIRD RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
THE FIRST TWO ATTEMPTS ENDED IN
EMBARRASSING DISASTERS.
THE THIRD WAS HEADED AT HIGH
SPEED IN THAT DIRECTION AND THEN
A SERIES OF UNFORESEEN FLUKES
AND HIGHLY CROWDED PRIMARY FIELD
LEFT BY THE LAST MINUTE OF THE
RACE.
HE WAS CLEARLY SHOCKED BY HIS
OWN VICTORY.
ON ELECTION NIGHT, THE 90 CLINCH
THE NOMINATION IN MARCH, BIDEN
WAS SO RATTLED HE MISTOOK HIS
SISTER FOR HIS WIFE DURING THE
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
AT THE TIME, JOE BIDEN’S
RELATIVE UNPOPULARITY SEEMED
LIKE A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS POLITICS, AFTER ALL.
APRIL WHO TEND TO HAVE THE MOST
SUPPORT TEND TO WIN.
SO IF YOU’RE CHOOSING A
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE, YOU THINK
YOU’D WANT SOMEONE WITH BUILT-IN
CONSTITUENCY, A BASE, A
PASSIONATE VOTERS YOU CAN COUNT
ON ELECTION DAY.
AS IT TURNS OUT THAT’S THE LAST
THING LEADERS OF THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTED.
THEY ALREADY HAD A CANDIDATE
LIKE THAT AND HIS NAME WAS
BERNIE SANDERS.
THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY COULD
TO STOP HIM.
NOW.
WHAT THEY WANTED INSTEAD WITH
SOMEONE THEY COULD CONTROL AND
JOE BIDEN FOR THAT DISCRETION
PERFECTLY.
BIDEN WAS EAGER, MALLEABLE, AND
TOTALLY BLANK.
HE WAS WILLING TO BE WHATEVER
HIS HANDLERS WANTED HIM TO BE.
KAMALA HARRIS WILL BE EVERY BIT
AS EAGER AND THAT’S THE POINT.
IF BIDEN AND HARRIS TO DOESN’T
MAKE SENSE TO YOU, IT’S ONLY
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT CYNICAL
ENOUGH.
HARRIS CLEARLY WASN’T PICKED FOR
HER PERSONAL CHARM.
MORE THAN 30 YEARS AGO SHE DATED
A MAN CALLED WILLIE BROWN WAS
LATER THE MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
SHE WAS 29 YEARS OLD AND BROWN
WAS 60 AND STILL MARRY.
BROWN LAUNCHED HARRIS’ POLITICAL
CAREER.
HE KNOWS VERY WELL.
LAST WEEK BROWN PROBABLY URGED
JOE BIDEN NOT TO PICK
KAMALA HARRIS AS HIS RUNNING
MATE.
IT TURNS OUT WILLIE BROWN’S
OPINION NO LONGER MATTERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
JEFF BEZOS’ OPINION MATTERS, SO
TO THE OPINIONS OF HIS FELLOW
BAY AREA TECH TITANS IN THE
FINANCE MOGULS IN NEW YORK.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
BANKROLLED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE THE ECONOMIC ENGINE OF
THE LEFT, AND THEY LOVE
KAMALA HARRIS.
NOT PERSONALLY.
IT’S BUSINESS.
THEIR MAIN INTEREST IS IN
KEEPING THE GOVERNMENT
CARVE OUTS THAT I MADE THEM
RICH.
THEY KNOW THE LAST THING
KAMALA HARRIS WILL DO IS
THREATEN ANY OF THOSE.
NEVER UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
ONE THING YOU CAN BE CERTAIN OF
THE IN A BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION, PRIVATE EQUITY
BARONS WILL STILL PAY HALF THE
TAX RATE YOU PAY.
THAT’S THE REAL POINT.
VOTERS MAY NOT LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS BUT WALL STREET
DOES.
JUST IN CASE YOU’RE WONDERING
WHO’S ACTUALLY IN CHARGE.
AND YET STILL, EVEN POLITICIANS
HAVE SOULS, TECHNICALLY ANYWAY.
HOW COULD JOE BIDEN PICK A
RUNNING MATE WHO ONCE PUBLICLY
DENOUNCED HIM AS RACIST?
HE REMEMBER THE MOMENT.
IT WAS IN THE DEBATE LAST
SUMMER.
IT’S BECOME GOING TO DIRECT THIS
TO VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU ARE A
RACIST.
BUT YOU ALSO WORKED WITH THEM TO
OPPOSE BUSING.
AND THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL, AND SHE WAS BUSED
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Tucker: I DO NOT BELIEVE
YOU ARE A RACIST.
I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU BEAT YOUR
WIFE.
RIGHT.
KAMALA HARRIS, CIVIL RIGHTS
ICON.
ACTUALLY HARRIS GROUP MOSTLY IN
CANADA AND IN ANY CASE FORCED
BUSING WAS A DISASTER FROM THE
BEGINNING TO THE END.
NOBODY LIKED IT, INCLUDING BLACK
FAMILIES.
JOE BIDEN MAY BE A BIGOT BUT
IT’S NOT BECAUSE HE OPPOSED
FORCED BUSING.
APPARENTLY HE HAS FORGIVEN
HARRIS FOR THAT SLUR.
MAYBE HE DOESN’T MEMBER IT.
EVEN A DIMMING 77-YEAR-OLD MUST
HAVE SOME MEMORY OF WHAT HARRIS
ONCE SAID ABOUT HIS PURPORTED
SEX CRIMES.
JUST LAST YEAR, SEVERAL WOMEN
CAME FORWARD TO SAY JOE BIDEN
HAD TOUCHED THEM IN AGGRESSIVE
WAYS ON AND OFF
CAMERA.
KAMALA HARRIS WHOLEHEARTEDLY
ENDORSED THEIR CLAIMS.
"I BELIEVE THEM AND I RESPECT
THEM BEING ABLE TO TELL THEIR
STORY AND HAVING THE COURAGE TO
DO IT."
WAIT, WHAT?
YOU BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED A NUMBER OF
WOMEN, SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THEM.
BUT YOU’RE JOINING HIS
PRESIDENTIAL TICKET ANYWAY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK EXACTLY?
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT?
AS IT TURNS OUT, SHE CAN DO IT
HAPPILY, SHAMELESSLY WITHOUT
EVEN TAKING A BREATH.
JUST TELL KAMALA HARRIS WHAT TO
SAY AND SHE WILL SAY IT.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF
KAMALA HARRIS.
IT’S WHY SHE’S SO USEFUL.
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS,
HARRIS IS GOING TO SAY THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A RACIST.
SHE WILL SAY THAT EVERY DAY
UNTIL NOVEMBER.
THAT’S HER JOB NOW.
YOU WATCH.
BUT KEEP IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
THERE’S NO FIGHTING BACK.
IT’S NOT ALLOWED.
KAMALA HARRIS IS A "HISTORIC"
CANDIDATE AND THAT MEANS YOU
HAVE NO RIGHT TO CRITICIZE HER
REGARDLESS OF WHAT SHE SAYS.
THEY ARE ALREADY TELLING YOU
THAT.
THEY ARE MAKING A CLEAR.
LAST WEEK A GROUP OF ABORTION
LOBBYISTS SENT A LETTER TO MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY
ABOUT BIDEN’S UPCOMING VP PICK.
IT WAS ADDRESSED TO EDITORS,
NEWS DIRECTORS, REPORTERS.
THE CHOICE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE WAS
MOST CERTAIN TO BE A BLACK WOMAN
THEY SAID.
THEY WERE RIGHT AND THEY WANTED
TO WARN REPORTERS THAT IN THE
WAKE OF GEORGE FLOYD’S DEATH,
ANY CRITICAL COVERAGE OF
JOE BIDEN’S VP PICK WHAT AMOUNT
TO "SYSTEMIC RACISM."
THAT WASN’T GUIDANCE.
IT WAS AN UNVEILED THREAT.
THEY MADE IT BECAUSE THEY KNEW
IT WOULD WORK AND IN FACT IT’S
ALREADY WORKING.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER HARRIS WAS
CHOSEN TODAY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SENT OUT A
BULLETIN DESCRIBING HER AS "A
PRAGMATIC MODERATE."
GOT THAT?
A PRAGMATIC MODERATE, NOT A
COOKIE IDEOLOGUE, NOT A FLAKY
LIBERAL FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
NO.
INSTEAD SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
SOLVE AMERICA’S TOUGHEST
PROBLEMS.
SOLVE THEM WITHOUT REGARD TO
ORTHODOXY OR PARTISANSHIP.
A SOBER, STEADY LEADER IN
TROUBLED TIMES.
ACTUALLY IT MIGHT BE NICE TO
HAVE SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
BUT THAT’S NOT KAMALA HARRIS,
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
HARRIS HAS ENDORSED FORCING
SCHOOLS TO LET BIOLOGICAL MALES
PLAN GIRLS ATHLETIC TEAMS.
IT’S NOT A MAJORITY POSITION.
IT’S NOT BUT IT’S NOT AS CRAZY
AS FEDERALLY SUBSIDIZED SUBSIDIZ
ABORTIONS FOR BIOLOGICAL MEN.
HARRIS IS FOR THAT TOO.
MEN CAN’T GET PREGNANT SO HOW DO
WE PAY FOR THEIR ABORTIONS?
HERE IS NEVER EXPLAINED IT IN
THIS POINT IT WOULD BE
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST TASK SO NO
ONE WILL EVER ASK.
SHUT UP.
NO QUESTIONS ALLOWED.
MEANWHILE THERE IS NOT A
FASHIONABLE RICH LADY POSITION
THAT KAMALA HARRIS DOESN’T HAVE.
PLASTIC STRAWS ARE BAD.
RED MEAT IS WORKED.
IF THERE WAS A BILL TO MAKE
SOULCYCLE MANDATORY,
KAMALA HARRIS WOULD GET BEHIND
IT.
>> DO YOU BAN PLASTIC STRAWS?
>> I THINK YOU SHOULD, YEAH.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT CHANGING
THE DIETARY GUIDELINES?
THE FOOD PYRAMID?
THEY GO YES.
SPEAKER REDUCE RED MEAT.
>> YES I WOULD.
>> Tucker: SO NOW YOU KNOW
KAMALA HARRIS’ POSITION ON THE
ALL-IMPORTANT FDA FOOD PYRAMID.
SHE HAS NONFRIVOLOUS POSITIONS
TOO.
ON HEALTH CARE HARRIS BELIEVES
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HAVE EVERY
BIT THE RIGHT TO TAXPAYER-FUNDED
MEDICAL TREATMENT THAT YOU DO AS
A CITIZEN.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER POSITION,
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF IT, THAT
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
SUPPORT.
AS WE HAVE NOTED, HARRIS DOESN’T
CARE WHAT MOST PEOPLE WANT.
THEY ARE NOT HER AUDIENCE.
SHE IS TOLD TO SUPPORT FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR FOREIGN
NATIONALS WHO BREAK OUR LAWS AND
SO SHE DOES.
>> YOU SUPPORT GIVING UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE AND MEDICARE FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
>> LET ME JUST BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THIS.
I AM OPPOSED TO ANY POLICY THAT
WOULD DENY IN OUR COUNTRY ANY
HUMAN BEING FROM ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
OR PUBLIC HEALTH.
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: KAMALA HARRIS ISN’T
AN IDIOT AND SHE KNOWS WHAT
SHE’S SUGGESTED IS ACTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE.
YOU CAN HAVE A WELFARE STATE.
LOTS OF COUNTRIES DO.
YOU CAN HAVE OPEN BORDERS.
YOU CAN’T HAVE BOTH.
NO COUNTRY CAN SURVIVE WITH A
WELFARE STATE AND OPEN BORDERS.
THAT’S OBVIOUS.
NO ONE DISPUTED.
KAMALA HARRIS DOESN’T CARE
EITHER WAY.
THE SURVIVAL SHE CARES ABOUT HIS
OR HER OWN SURVIVAL.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU THINK YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR FAMILY SAFE AS A
COUNTRY COLLAPSES AROUND HER
AMBITIONS, YOU’RE WRONG BECAUSE
SHE PLANS TO DISARM YOU FIRST.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IN THE
MANDATORY BUYBACK OF
QUOTE-UNQUOTE ASSAULT WEAPONS?
>> I DO BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO
BUYBACKS.
THEY ARE WEAPONS OF WAR.
WITH NO PLACE ON THE STREETS OF
A CIVIL SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: WE COULD GO ON AND
ON.
OH, THE IRONIES.
THE PARTY THAT IS ANGRY ABOUT
POLICE BRUTALITY HAS JUST HIRED
THE FORMER CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN, THERE’S A LOT TO SAY AND
IN COMING WEEKS WE’LL SAY IT.
IS A LOT OF AVAILABLE TAPE AND
HARRIS WILL SOON PROVIDE MORE.
WE WILL SUM UP KAMALA HARRIS
THIS WAY.
LAST YEAR WHEN DR. JUSSIE
SMOLLETT STAGED HIS FAKE
HATE CRIME, HARRIS WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST NATIONAL LEADERS TO
JUMP IN WITH POSITION OF
SUPPORT.
HE WAS THE KINDEST MOST GENTLE
HUMAN BEING HARRIS HAD EVER MET,
SHE WROTE.
THE ATTACK ON HIM WAS "AN
ATTEMPTED MODERN-DAY LYNCHING.
POST QUOTE OKAY, SHE FELL FOR
IT.
LOTS OF CREDULOUS RICH PEOPLE
DEAD BUT WHAT MAKES
KAMALA HARRIS A REMARKABLE
FIGURE?
IS IT IN THE FACE OF CHANGING
EVIDENCE SHE NEVER CAN CENTER
SUPPORT THAT WE DISTILL UP SHE
DID NOT DELETED.
YOU CAN STILL READ IT ON HER
TWITTER FEED TONIGHT.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT’S STORY WAS
ENTIRELY CONCOCTED.
HARRIS KNOWS IT.
WE ALL KNOW IT.
SHE DOESN’T CARE.
HARRIS UNDERSTANDS PRIVATELY
WELL WHY JUSSIE SMOLLETT LIED,
BY SMEARING TRUMP SUPPORTERS AS